à l'insee la mobilité sociale et et
mesuré par la mobilité
socioprofessionnelles c'est à dire que
vous pouvez passer là c'est à dire qu'on
me compare la catégorie
socioprofessionnelle la pcs d'une
personne à celle de ses parents et on
fait ainsi des analyses de trajectoire
inter-générationnelle alors l'avantagé
d'utiliser la pcs la catégorie
socioprofessionnelle c'est une mesure
qui est stable dans le temps et ce
depuis 1982 un autre de ces avantages
c'est que c'est une nomenclature qui a
été conçu pour combiner plusieurs
facteurs métier revenus diplôme mais on
peut aussi choisir de mesurer la
mobilité sociale à partir d'un seul de
ces deux facteurs de ces facteurs pardon
pour qu'on considère qu'il y a mobilité
sociale lorsque la personne et son
parent relève de catégorie socio
professionnelle différente et qu'il ay
ay ay mobilité ou reproduction sociale
lorsque la personne et son parent on l'a
même pcs pour effectuer cette
comparaison ont fait le choix d'un par
an pendant longtemps ça a été le père on
y reviendra et on fait vraiment deux
photos un pour l'enfant et un pour le
parent en faisant en sorte de se placer
à h comparables alors la source
principale de données qui permet le
suivi de la mobilité sociale à l'insee
celle enquête formation et qualification
professionnelle fqp c'est une source qui
existe depuis 1964 depuis cette enquête
ont été réalisés dont la dernière en
2014 2015
c'est une enquête qui est très riche
donc elle permet de mesurer l'origine
sociale en récoltant notamment la pcs et
le diplôme des deux parents mais elle
dispose aussi de beaucoup d'informations
sur les parcours de formation la
scolarité initiale la formation
professionnelle sur la mobilité en cours
de carrière sur et sur les liens donc
avec l'emploi et les revenus tirés du
travail
donc elle permet des comparaisons
temporel grâce à la reprise à
l'identique de questions d'une édition à
l'autre et donc ce sur longue période
une hausse notre source possible pour
avoir une mesure de la mobilité sociale
celle enquête emploi
on y collecte en effet la profession et
donc la pcs des deux parents mais par
exemple on y collecte pas de façon
continuelle le diplôme des parents on à
la profession des pères depuis 1982 dans
cette enquête est la profession des mers
depuis 2003 cette enquête et disponibles
annuellement mais on peut noter que la
mobilité sociale étant un phénomène
structurel il n'ya pas nécessairement de
sens a observé l'observer tous les ans
en observer les variations annuelles
à noter l'enquète emploi a été rénové
donc là en 2021 et les questions sur
l'origine sociale sont désormais alignée
sur celle de l' enquête est occupée ce
qui devrait permettre d'en améliorer la
qualité car jusqu'ici en fait la pcs des
mers était assez mal renseigné et ce à
limiter les possibilités d'exploitation
de l'anc est un autre avantage l'enquète
emploi couvre les dom ce qui n'est pas
le cas de l'enquète fqp qui sur le champ
métropole avec seulement en 2015 la
dernière un échantillon sur la réunion
et la guadeloupe alors
là vous avez quelques exemples de
référence clé mais c'est très succinct
de travaux de recherche notamment sur la
mobilité sociale l'insee fournit avec
les enquêtes fqp et enquêtes emploi les
informations de base les moyens de
mesurer la mobilité sociale et ce sur
longue période
l'introduction de ces questions dès
l'origine dans enquêtes fqp en 1964 a
contribué à développer l'intérêt sur ce
thème et en retour a fait de cette
enquête une source un peu privilégié des
analyses sur cette thématique
la recherche en sciences sociales sont
nés très largement apparaît si vous avez
vraiment quelque chose de très brefs
une analyse socio vous allez un tout
petit peu trop été une analyse socio
historique de 2010 notez que la
thématique des inégalités sociales et de
leurs productions représenter les deux
tiers des publications qui avait été
réalisé à partir des éditions 64 à 2003
des enquêtes est occupé là vous pouvez
passer à l'autre l'insee publie aussi de
façon régulière sur la question même si
de façon moins fourni ces derniers temps
donc là aussi vous avez quelques
références à ses récentes et des
analyses sur longue période notamment à
partir des enquêtes est occupé et on va
pas on va aborder à partir des toutes
dernières qui sont cités ici dans le
second temps de cette présentation
quelques grands résultats tirés des
dernières exploitations
on peut passer alors comment la mobilité
sociale at elle évolué en france ces
dernières années on peut passer je suis
france alors les analyses de la mobilité
sociale
on entend porter uniquement sur les
hommes parce que le faible taux
d'activité des femmes et les
caractéristiques de leur emploi ont
rendu difficiles pendant longtemps la
comparaison de leurs positions
professionnelles avec celle de leurs
parents
mais au cours des dernières décennies
bien ce taux d'activité des femmes et
les caractéristiques des emplois se sont
rapprochés de ceux des hommes
et désormais il est possible de
s'intéresser à la mobilité sociale des
femmes
donc on peut comparer la pcs des femmes
à celle de leur mère alors évidemment la
moindre participation des mères au
marché du travail
limite le champ d'analysé puisque les
femmes dont la mère n'a jamais travaillé
sont exclus du champ ceci étant sur les
dernières années on peut quand même
comparé sur longue période sur des
échantillons suffisamment grand pour
pour être pour que les résultats soient
fiables et de manière complémentaire on
peut comparer toujours les femmes à
leurs pairs dans les quelques résultats
qu'on va vous présenter on utilise la
nomenclature suivante donc à partir des
pcs en six catégories avec deux
catégories d'indépendants et quatre
catégories de salariés de façon assez
classique donc l'hiérarchie zay comme
suit 1 cadres professions intermédiaires
employés ouvriers avec une petite
différence par rapport à d'habitude les
employés ouvriers sont regroupés mais
distinguer selon qu'ils sont qualifiés
ou non qualifié le champ d'analysé ce
sont les personnes qui sont en emploi ou
bien qu'ils ont été qui ont travaillé
dans ce cas l'on regarde la pcs du
dernier emplois qu'elles ont occupé ces
les personnes âgées de 35 à 50 devant et
on compare leurs pcs à celle de leur
père ou leur mère à la fin de leurs
études
on considère anglais parents étaient à
ce moment là dans cette même tranche
d'âge de 35 50 devant alors sur les
résultats et bien
si on regarde entre 1977 et 2015 pour
les hommes on constate une mobilité
sociale qui est resté quasi stable
environ deux tiers des hommes relève
d'une catégorie socioprofessionnelle
différentes de celles de leurs pairs aux
deux dates et c'est la même chose si on
regarde sur les vingt dernières années
entre 1993 et 2000 15 pour les femmes en
en 2015 d'une mobilité sociale qui
dépasse celle des hommes puisque 71%
d'entre elles ont une pièce différente
de celle de leur mère et 70% de peces
différentes de celles de leurs pairs ce
taux de mobilité sociale a progressé de
12 points en 40 ans par rapport au maire
et de 6 points en 40 ans par rapport aux
pairs en revanche si on regarde juste
les vingt dernières années donc entre 93
et 2015 en date des enquêtes fqp on est
sur un taux de mobilité sociale stable
aux environs de 70 % par rapport au
maire et par rapport aux pairs sur cette
période la société française a connu de
grandes transformations l'essor du
salariat le recul de l'emploi industriel
tertiarisation de l'économie le
développement de l'emploi qualifié ça
évidemment des impacts sur la mesure
qu'on fait de la mobilité sociale en
particulier la forte décroissance de
l'emploi non salariés entraîne
naturellement moins de mobilité entre
catégories non salariés indépendants et
salariés les mobilités qu'on dit de
statut et corollaire il y à davantage de
mobilité entre les catégories de
salariés celle qu'on appelle la mobilité
verticale parce que ces catégories de
salariés
on arrive à les hiérarchiser donc on à
la fois plus de mouvements ascendants et
plus de mouvement descendant mais les
mouvements ascendants reste plus
fréquent que les descendants pour les
hommes par rapport à leurs pairs et pour
les femmes par rapport à leur mère
toutefois pour les hommes sur la période
la prédominance des mouvements
ascendants s'est réduite est
essentiellement au cours des vingt
dernières années pour les femmes on a
plus de mouvements ascendants du ca
s'explique par le niveau socio
professionnelle des mères qui est
nettement inférieur à celui des pères si
on compare les femmes par rapport à
leurs pairs cette fois les mobilités
descendante sont sur toute la période
toujours plus fréquentes que les
mobilité ascendante
autre point on l'a dit sur longue
période ya de gros effets de structure
on peut essayer de quantifier la part de
la mobilité sociale qui est lié à
l'évolution de la structure des emplois
d'une génération à l'autre la part de la
mobilité structurelles donc cette part
elle est pour les hommes de 24 % en 2015
et 2 35% pour les femmes
cette part de la mobilité structurelle
elle a baissé en fait sur les quarante
ans qu'on observe ici et elle a levé
c'est davantage pour les hommes que pour
les femmes
en fait les modifications de la
structure des emplois masculins se sont
sont surtout intervenus au sortir des
trente glorieuses et au cours des 40
dernières années la structure des
emplois des hommes et celle de leur père
se sont rapprochés pour les femmes et il
ya davantage de changements depuis la
fin des trente glorieuses
il ya aussi un rapprochement de la
structure des emplois des femmes et
celle de leur mère mais il est moins
marquée ce graphique on peut passer il
est il ne fait qu'illustrer les éléments
que je viens de dire alors si on
s'intéresse maintenant à la fluidité
sociale
ce qu'on appelle la fluidité sociale
c'est une mesure en fait on compare les
chances relative d'accéder à une
catégorie socioprofessionnelle plutôt
qu'à une autre en fonction de l'origine
sociale
c'est une forme de mesure d'égalité des
chances on constate pour les femmes
comme pour les hommes que la fluidité
sociale a fortement progressé entre tous
les groupes sociaux sur cette période
des 40 en mai
la réduction des inégalités s'est
principalement déroulée entre la fin des
années 70 et le début des années 90 et
elle a tendance à stagner depuis donc on
va l'illustré avec la démo suivante
là vous avez une mesure de la fluidité
sociale entre la catégorie cadres et la
catégorie employés ouvriers qualifiés
si vous regardez juste la courbe bleue
par exemple en 1977
on a un fils de cadres qui a 28 fois
plus de chances qu'un fils d'ouvriers
employés qualifiés de devenir cadre
plutôt qu'ouvrier employés qualifiés en
un fils de cadre à n'a plus que si on
peut dire douze fois plus de chances
qu'un fils d'ouvriers employés qualifiés
de devenir cadres et si on regarde en
on est sur ce même écart de 12 fois plus
de chances donc entre ces catégories
sociales et sur ce graphique là on voit
très nettement le palier qui intervient
à partir du début des années 90 voilà
pour terminer
quelques résultats d'une autre étude
toujours à partir de l'enquète fqp mais
avec une approche complémentaire celle
de la mobilité subjective ou ressenti
jeudi le début la paix c'est c'est une
mesure stable dans le temps et c'est un
de ces gros avantage mais c'est aussi
une limite parce qu'elle ne rend pas
compte de l'évolution de la hiérarchie
des emplois on peut exercer la même
profession que son père et en avoir une
appréciation différente au regard des
évolutions de la société parce que
l'emploi qualifié a augmenté et on qu'on
le constate donc à partir de ce qu paix
2003 il y à une question qui permet de
mesurer une mobilité ressenti alors de
façon assez cohérente avec la hausse
globale de la qualification des emplois
en 2015 on a près de 4 personnes sur 10
qui exprime un sentiment d'ascension
sociale
on en a un quart qui se considèrent
déclassé socialement
ce qu'on constate aussi c'est qu'il ya
un lien assez fort entre la mobilité
sociale qu'on mesure avec la pcs et la
mobilité ressenti il est plus fréquent
de se sentir des classes et quand on est
dans une mobilité descendante et dans ce
cas-là plus il ya des quarts entre la
pcs du père est la sienne plus le
sentiment de déclassement est fréquent
mais le sentiment de déclassement il
concerne aussi des personnes qui ont une
mobilité descendante une mobilité statut
ou qui appartiennent à la même place et
est ce que leur père en particulier
34% des personnes qui sont cadres comme
leur père ressentent un déclassement
alors cette étude elle fait aussi une
analyse un peu plus finement avec une
analyse par profession et elle fait un
lien entre le sentiment de déclassement
et les conditions d'emploi notamment pas
seulement mais notamment au sein des
employés des ouvriers le sentiment de
déclassement est d'autant plus fréquent
pour les personnes les professions qui
ont les conditions d'emploi moins
favorable vous avez quelques catégories
citées ci où il ya eric hall caissiers
vendeurs non spécialisés serveur c'est
des catégories des professions ou le
temps partiel subi
les contrats précaires le chômage les
revenus aussi son jean moins bon et
c'est en lien avec le sentiment de
déclassement plus fréquents voilà je
vous remercie de votre attention très
bien vers ces jeux des rup oui bonjour à
tous merci beaucoup de m'avoir invité à
présenter les travaux de france tratégie
sur les questions de mobilité sociale
et puis merci aussi d'avoir organisé cet
événement dans la vraie vie parce que ça
fait quand même plusieurs mois que on ne
fait que des conférences par zoom et
autres donc c'est très appréciable dans
le respect des distances etc
alors je vais commencer par attendant de
définition de remarques méthodologique
ensuite vous présenterait rapidement un
certain nombre de travaux que nous avons
publiée récemment sur la question de la
mobilité sur les revenus
et puis j'essaierai de répondre à la
question que kim avait été posée quand
on m'avait invité à savoir la france
fait-elle pire que ses voisins et
cessent de pire en pire en quelque sorte
donc si on peut passer à la première
slide s'il vous plaît d'abord quelques
définitions étudier la reproduction d
inhaler les inégalités qu'est ce que
c'est c'est se demander dans quelle
mesure le statut des parents qu'on peut
mesurer de différentes manières soit par
la profession comme vient de présenter
l'insee soit par les revenus le
patrimoine le niveau d'éducation et
encore d'autres dimensions et donc dans
quelle mesure le statut des parents se
transmet en moyenne à leurs enfants
j'insiste sur le en moyenne parce que
dans les débats sur la mobilité sociale
on a tendance à voir l'inégalité des
chances comme impur déterminisme social
enfin l'effet d'un pur déterminisme
social total c'est à dire que l'origine
sociale déterminerait la trajectoire et
les revenus la profession des enfants or
c'est vrai en moyenne mais évidemment à
un niveau individuel
pour le dire assez simplement on va
retrouver des enfants d'ouvriers parmi
les ménages aisés parmi les ménages plus
modestes et inversement on va retrouver
des ménages qui ont une origine
enfin qui ont des parents cadres parmi
les ménages aisés parmi les ménages
modestes donc il ya des gens qui se
retrouvent en haut et en bas de la
distribution des revenus et des
professions et est finalement l'origine
sociale n'explique qu'une part marginale
de l'inégalité de revenus dans la
société
c'est environ 15% des inégalités de
revenus qui sont expliquées par
l'origine sociale ce qui veut dire qu'en
gros on à 85% de l'inégalité qui est de
l'inégalité à origine sociale donnée à
l'intérieur de deux catégories sociales
d'origine sociale donnée est donc encore
une fois l'idée c'est que on va avoir
une inégalité des chances entre enfants
d'ouvriers enfants de cadres en moyenne
mais que parler de déterminisme social
c'est vous le dire rapidement allé
au-delà de ce que de ce que nous disent
les données alors plusieurs approches
sont complémentaires dans l'étude de la
mobilité sociale
j'ai parlé des différentes dimensions la
profession le revenu et le patrimoine le
niveau des 8 éducation
ce qui est compliqué vous le verrez
c'est la disponibilité des données
notamment au niveau international et
donc la plupart des études se sont
concentrés sur la profession et le
revenu avec des limites très importante
d'ailleurs sur lesquelles je reviendrai
rapidement et affrontera tj nous avons
voulu insister sur la dimension de
revenus donc avec un premier éclairage
si on peut passer au stade suivant où on
a regardé c'est une publication de 2018
on a regardé l'origine sociale des
différents des cils de revenus donc là
chaque barre verticale représente un des
cils de revenus donc les plus modestes
à gauche les plus aisés à droite avec un
zoom sur le top 10 pour cent donc ce
sont les les bars de droite et même un
zoom sur le top 09 1%
donc c'est le l'avant dernière barre au
dessus de ses 99
est ce que montrent ces bars et la
composition en termes d'origine sociale
des différents des cils de revenus donc
vous voyez que plus on va vers la droite
plus la couleur bleu turquoise qui
représente les enfants de cadres
supérieurs plus cette couleur prendre la
place jusqu'à représenter quasiment la
moitié tout à droite dans le dans le top
20 % c'est-à-dire que plus vous allez
dans les hauts revenus m'ont plu vous
avez d'enfants de cadres et moi vous
avez d'enfants d'ouvriers et notamment
d'ouvriers non qualifiés ce sont les
couleurs bleu foncé en bas du graphique
encore une fois on retrouve quand même
des enfants d'ouvriers et d'employés
même au sein du top 10 pour cent même au
sein du top 20 pour cent des revenus
il n'y a pas de déterminisme pure sur
sur le destin des individus de l'origine
sociale
mais évidemment tournés vers la droite
plus être cadré et moyen des ouvriers
alors ça c'est pour les constats sur
l'origine sociale
si on peut passer aux seuils des
suivants s'il vous plaît une autre
manière de représenter ces données
et de regarder le destin des individus
selon la profession de leurs parents
donc là vous avez ce sont exactement les
mêmes données du graphique précédent
mais présentés d'une manière différente
où là on vous dit la probabilité d'accès
des enfants selon leurs origines
sociales au top 20 pour cent des revenus
saas et les barbes le versus aux 20% des
revenus les plus faibles
ce sont les bars orange est donc là vous
voyez que évidemment il ya une et des
inégalité des chances très importante au
sens où la probabilité d'un enfant de
professions libérales et cinq fois
d'accéder aux 20% des revenus les plus
élevés et cinq fois plus importantes que
les probabilités d'un enfant d'ouvrier
agricole et inversement les probabilités
d'accès au bas de la distribution des
revenus sont plus importantes pour les
individus d'origine modeste
donc on avait mesuré qu environ 1000
euros par mois au niveau de vie séparée
un enfant de cadre et un enfant
d'ouvrier et un autres résultats
complémentaires de l'étude c'était que
sur ces 1000 euros il y en a 500 qui
viennent des écarts de niveau
d'éducation entre les enfants de cas
d'enfants d'ouvriers donc en gros
l'éducation explique enfin c'est le
canal qui expliquent la moitié la part
la plus importante et la moitié des
écarts selon l'origine sociale et donc
le facteur éducatif est primordial si on
veut lutter contre la reproduction des
inégalités alors les autres 500 euros ça
va être des différences qui sont pas
liées au niveau de diplôme et qui vont
être liés à la qualité du diplôme à
l'orientation dans les filières
certaines professions vont s'orienter
dans des filières plus professionnelle
d'autre des filières qui vont l'emmener
vers des des fonds les amener vers des
professions mieux vaut mieux rémunérés
et puis après il ya les facteurs qui
sont propres à l'insertion sur le marché
du travail
à diplôme donné vous insérez mieux si
vous avez un réseau social plus
conséquent si vous êtes fils de 4 vous
avez un réseau social plus conséquent en
moyenne que si vous êtes un enfant
d'ouvrier et donc vous allez vous
insérez mieux alors ça c'est pour la
dimension origines sociales on a fait
une étude complémentaire pour
s'interroger sur la dimension
territoriale de l'inégalité des chances
on va passer à la slide suivante là on
se concentre sur des individus qui ont
la même origine sociale en l'occurrence
des enfants d'ouvriers d'employés
certains d'entre eux peu près 40% de la
population et on compare le niveau de
vie à l'âge adulte de ses enfants de ses
enfants d'ouvriers selon leur territoire
d'origine donc là c'est une carte où on
montre là où les gens ont grandi c'est
pas là où les gens résident forcément
grande partie des gens résident là où
ils ont grandi mais aussi des gens qui
bougent
là la carte elle dit par exemple que
à paris le niveau val
parmi les enfants d'ouvriers et
d'employés qui ont grandi à paris le
niveau de vie médian est de l'ordre de
1700 euros contre 1400 euros à calais à
lille ou à perpignan est donc cette
carte elle montre quoi elle fait
apparaître des grandes continuité de
couleur donc ça veut dire que on a des
grandes régions qui vont être favorable
donc ça ça va être
l'île de france là les jeunes les plus
favorables sont enfoncés ça va être
l'ile-de-france les zones frontalières
de la suisse
l'alsace le sud-ouest toulouse un
certain nombre de grandes métropoles
aussi et al'inverse on a un ensemble de
territoires concentré au nord et au sud
du pays qui sont peu favorables aux
individus donc principalement dans les
hautes france et puis au sud de
l'ancienne en région
languedoc-roussillon et en corse
donc donc avant tout si on s'intéresse à
la dimension territoriale de l'inégalité
de destin on se rend compte que les
écarts sont avant tout régionaux à
l'intérieur des régions on a finalement
assez peu d'écart entre grandes villes
petites villes territoires ruraux
si vous prenez le cas particulier de
l'île de france vous remarqué aussi que
la seine-saint-denis est plutôt foncée
donc c'est un terrain territoire qui est
très pauvre mais faisant partie d'une
région très riche et donc les individus
qui grandissent finalement bénéficient
de ce niveau de développement plus élevé
en région ile-de france et donc vont
avoir des perspectives plus importante
que les individus de même origine
sociale qui ont grandi dans le nord pas
de calais par exemple et l'autre
enseignement c'est que bien sûr les
écarts entre territoires ils sont
fortement liées au développement
régional et un peu comment dire pas
autant qu'on aurait pensé au niveau
d'éducation on a des niveaux d'éducation
qui vont varier selon le territoire
d'origine mais ces niveaux d'éducation
il explique finalement assez peu d écart
que vous constatez sur la carte et donc
c'est vraiment bêtement si je puis dire
le niveau de développement du territoire
qui va qui va expliquer les inégalités
de destin
oui alors malheureusement la lozère
comme souvent étant un territoire peu
peuplé ne parvient pas à réunir
suffisamment d'observation dans les
données pour que ça soit statistiquement
significatifs donc là on est parti des
données de l'échantillon démographique
permanent qui est produit par l'insee
on avait à peu près cent mille individus
on a fixé un seuil pour que ça ait un
sens de mémoire de 150 individus et donc
la lozère voilà donc la lozère là c'est
le fait que la lozère est très peu dense
et que voilà c'est vrai je suis d'accord
il n'ya pas les dogues n'ont plus sait
on en avait espéré pouvoir inclure les
dom également et ce n'est pas possible
non donc si on passe au slide suivant
donc je vous disais que les écarts
étaient avant tout régionaux peu d'écart
entre zones rurales et zones et villes
moyennes ou grandes métropoles
on a quand même des écarts importants de
destin à une échelle fine qui est
l'échelle du quartier donc si vous ou
mais à l'intérieur des grandes
métropoles
si vous dézinguer les quartiers
favorisés et les quartiers les moins
favorisés donc là on est sur des données
je les ai pas dit mais on est sur
l'échantillon démographique permanent
on est sur des données qui dure sur une
trentaine d'années on a regardé les
enfants dans les années 90 où est-ce
qu'ils ont grandi et on a observé ce
qu'ils sont devenus aujourd'hui donc là
l'idée c'est qu'on a regardé les
quartiers défavorisés ou favoriser des
grandes métropoles dans les années 90 et
on a regardé quels étaient les
inégalités de destin et on retrouve
encore des inégalités importantes au
sein de
la plupart des grandes métropoles à
quelques exceptions comme nice ou la
région parisienne et ce qui était
important aussi c'est que à cette
échelle-là l'échelle des quartiers
c'est vraiment le niveau d'éducation qui
va expliquer les écarts de destin c'est
à dire que si vous grandissez dans un
territoire peut favoriser à l'intérieur
d'une métropole ou d'une grande
agglomération
vous allez moins souvent qu'ailleurs
faire des études supérieures et c'est ce
facteur là qui va faire que vous aurez
des perspectives de revenus plus faibles
alors on va passer au stade suivant s'il
vous plaît je sais pas si j'ai encore un
peu de temps mais donc gelé très vite la
susurre finalement ce qu'on sait
vraiment de la mobilité
intergénérationnel des revenus en france
en comparaison internationale
c'est un sujet qui paradoxalement
et très peu documentée c'est à dire que
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
il ya très peu de données qui permettent
d'observer les revenus des parents et
les revenus des enfants de manière
précise pas ce qu'il faut en fait
compiler des données sur plusieurs
décennies retracé l'historique des
individus et si on veut si on veut faire
bien les choses
ça coûte cher et très peu de pays
disposent des données qui sont qui
permet de faire un tel travail
essentiellement en scandinavie aux états
unis et pour le reste on a des données
de qualité relativement modeste on va
dire notamment sur la france comme dans
beaucoup de pays les revenus des parents
sont imputés dans toutes les études
c'est à dire que les études ne peuvent
pas directement observer le revenu des
parents donc il ya une méthode indirecte
qui s'ouvre un certain nombre de biais
et qui est utilisé et il n'y a pas mieux
aujourd'hui deux approches
complémentaires dans la littérature une
approche sur l'inertie des revenus donc
on va regarder dans quelle mesure des
écarts de revenus entre parents se
transmettent à la génération d'après en
euros et une autre approche en termes de
reproduction de la position où là on va
n'ont pas regardé les revenus on va
regarder la position des parents c'est à
dire dans le rang des parents et le rang
des enfants et dans quelle mesure le
rang des deux générations et lee alors
pour la france on n'a que des résultats
sur l'inertie des revenus donc encore
une fois c'est la part de l'écart entre
deux parents qui subsistent à la
génération suivante et le chiffre qu'il
faut retenir on a plusieurs estimations
qui sont relativement concordantes
compte tenu de l'imperfection des
données que j'ai dit tout à l'heure avec
une inertie de l'ordre de 40%
donc si vous avez un écart de 100 entre
deux parents l'écart entre les ans les
enfants de ces parents là sera de 40
alors c'est beaucoup plus que les bons
élèves pas scander de la ville et
scandinavie le canada taux tourne plutôt
autour d'une inertie de 10 ou 20%
sur 1 / en écart de 100 il reste 10 10
la génération d'après nous il reste 40
ça c'est les bons élèves mais la france
n'est pas forcément le pire élève pour
autant c'est à dire qu'on se situe
dans un groupe ii voilà deux pays avec
de la madeleine et de l'inégalité des
chances au même titre que les états unis
l'allemagne le royaume uni et et encore
d'autres pays et l'autre résultat c'est
qu'on a peu d'évolution significative
dans le temps 1
on n'a pas de preuve que finalement en
tout cas depuis une trentaine d'années
il y est une une amélioration ou houle
inverse sur l'inertie c'est les données
ne sont pas de qualité suffisante pour
pouvoir conclure à ce sujet donc est-ce
qu'on pourrait passer à l'as lattes
suivante merci non mais je vais je vais
pas rentrer là-dedans jouer justin j'ai
pas j'ai pas forcément le temps de
développer je voulais juste souligner un
paradoxe sur la france qui était que la
france se caractérise
contrairement à ce qu'on dit souvent par
une baisse de l'inégalité de revenus sur
longue période alors que dans la plupart
des pays comparables
en occident on a plutôt une hausse
tendancielle de l'inégalité de revenus
en france l inverse on que c'est ce que
vous voyez sur sur ce graphique et et le
paradoxe c'est que normalement ça
devrait jouer en faveur de la france
c'est à dire que si l'inégalité baisse
par rapport aux autres pays
ça devrait avoir un effet favorable sur
l'inertie
c'est à dire ça devrait baisser
l'inertie des revenus on ne devrait pas
avoir une inertie aussi importante et
donc
le nerf de résoudre le paradoxe est
peut-être de dire que la france est
caractérisé par peut-être un niveau de
reproduction des positions qui est
important et qui fait que même si on ya
une réduction des inégalités dans le
temps eh bien on va avoir quand même une
inertie qui va être qui va être
importante je pourrais répondre à vos
questions sur les aspects plus
techniques là je brosse vraiment un gros
traits est-ce qu'on peut passer au slide
suivant et donc je veux encore souligné
le fait que les données sont
perfectibles notamment en france malgré
les investissements énormes et très
coûteux qui sont qui ont été réalisés et
il ya quand même une note d'espoir c'est
que l'échantillon démographique
permanent sur lequel lindsay a investi
depuis maintenant je pense qu'une
quarantaine d'années non c'est ça va
permettre vraiment d'ici un horizon
relativement proche de considérablement
améliorer notre connaissance sur ces
questions là puisque l'on va avoir des
échantillons vraiment conséquent et donc
d'ici cinq ans on pourra dire beaucoup
plus de choses malheureusement je ne
pourrai pas vous en dire plus
aujourd'hui et peut-être une dernière
sly sur la question des héritages
puisque vous aviez évoqué ce sujet dans
dans l'invitation
on a fait une note sur le retour des
héritages en france sur longue période
ou montrait que les flux de transmission
de patrimoine avait augmenté très de
façon très importante depuis une
trentaine d'années les héritages c'était
8% c'était l'équivalent de 10% du revenu
disponible
il ya une trentaine d'années et ses 20%
aujourd'hui et selon nous ça va encore
augmenter jusqu'à un chiffre de l'ordre
de 35% au milieu du siècle et donc
derrière cette question du retour de
l'héritage est aussi la question de
l'inégalité des chances puisque avec en
plus dans le futur
les baby boomers qui vont transmettre
leur patrimoine
on sait que parmi ces générations le
patrimoine est très concentré et donc
l'idée c'est est ce que on risque pas
d'avoir une société à deux vitesses dans
les décennies qui viennent
l'héritage se rajoutant comme facteur
d'inégalité des chances puisque un
individu sur deux méritent que de très
peu ouvre le sommes relativement
modestes
donc peut-être que l'héritage va être
facteur d'inégalité des chances mais
encore une fois la question des données
va être essentiel parce que on ne soit
on ne sait pas aujourd'hui exactement
mesurer l'ampleur de l'effet des
héritages sur l'inégalité des chances du
simple fait que on hérite tard et donc
il est compliqué de savoir dans quelle
mesure un individu va être aidé par ses
parents par ses grands parents est de
savoir dans quelle mesure le patrimoine
va s'ajouter aux revenus comme facteur
d'inégalité de l'essence ou au contraire
au pouvoir dans certains cas pouvoir
compenser des inégalités de revenus donc
voilà je vous remercie
il est très important à chaque fois
surtout quand on a des conséquences au
niveau d'action politique publique dès
qu'elles quittent où il est et non pas
parce qu'il ya plusieurs facettes
dimension déjà il ya l'aspect qui était
maintenant c'était la mobilité intel
générationnel contre la volonté des
enfants
mais ce qui est important aussi c'est
bien simple volonté individuelle à
mobility recours l'existence des
individus tiens tiens
nous allons donc c'est ici dans le
rapport qui est sorti il ya deux ans on
s'y tient du fonds d'innovation dont la
première représentation
surtout le troisième volet il se l'est
de stations socioprofessionnelles à
farcir les classes sociales qui est
plutôt un focus des études sociologiques
il ya aussi voulait lever 9 nuls et bien
d'activité les revenus disponibles le
patrimoine est ce qui était aux avait ça
il ya expiation scellier bien si la
mobilité en termes d'éducation que nous
avons été et finalement est ce qui est
le moins discuté dans le pain beurre et
en public mais ce qui est important
merci à l'aspect de mobilité de santé il
ya peut être des emportements en ce
moment là et ensuite c'est donc tous ses
dimensions bien sûr il ya deux degrés à
concevoir c'est une banalité absolue
l'homme à quelle mesure le niveau
d'éducation le salaire de revenus réels
et plus or il n'est que celui des
parents
dans des sociétés plus riches il n'y a
plus un focus sur la mort i télé latif
donc la première la monétaire solution
de l'invité c'est devolder de
l'ascenseur social qu'est le deuxième
c'est une position sur l'ascenseur donc
ou anciens trouvent les aléas de la
position de harengs et je rajoute aussi
parce qu'ici sur cette image vous voyez
tous les personnes après l'autre mais
bien sûr il ya une différence
les rangs sont pas tout à fait pareil
mais à certains qui sont très bas et
certains très haut sur cet été ici par
exemple où il est très bien ici
si aux indices us de nos familles ou aux
noix un point haut atteint le niveau de
casse hier et aux adultes ya des chances
que vous avez là on atteint 60
rapportant ça c'est donc au lait en
france est le plus fort c'est 70% par
contre si vous êtes issus de familles
aucun du marathon et le 10 ème cycle
secondaire saint-aubin 13 passes en plus
en france 10 5%
et je rajoute c'est ce qui est important
à 1300 pouces
il ya eu 2 qui arrive ça va donc il ya
les génies t on au dub et c'est très
important ça c'est le niveau éducation
en génération nous on regarde la
mobilité au coût de la vie la vie nous
disposons pas des dons dès lors que la
vie met en disposent 9 qui peut suivre
les gens 5 à x 10 ans
si on regarde cinq ans et c'est toujours
en bas et c'est toujours long de l'essai
où il ya le plus agité mais si vous
voyez il ya 55 % sur cinq ans dans les
années 2010 des personnes qui sont parmi
les 1 1% le plus pauvre et qui le reste
et par contre pour nous cette inertie et
davantage prononcé ces 70% en france 60
à 63 et 66 ans il convient aussi de dire
que cette mobilité au cours du livre
c'est mobilité individuelle à remonter
depuis les années 90 200 points de
pourcentage et en bas et on nous
envoyait nos cellules et là où mon team
combat pour la france est restée barrée
au l'offre en solo
et puisque j'avais dans mon point de vue
je fais c'est souligner qu'il faut
toujours y aller surtout quand on
compare entre pays
de quelle dimension nous allons dans le
film un grand tableau là je viens juste
un extrait avec des ponts cibles au sol
de plus certains pays émergents
et si je suis le premier d'une façon si
vous voulez bien
donc déjà on a sacrifié les pays bas
groupe e pays avec niveau d'inégalité
d'aujourd'hui enfin s'il me dit il
moyenne élevée
vous avez un douzaine de mises en
chantier quand même je fais une
sélection des quatre appuis pour chacun
de ces trois années et ensuite on a
regardé ici j'en ai un premier où on
connaît le niveau de mobilité
intergénérationnel donc entre en
fréquents dans sa part aux enfants est
ici c'est la mobilité individuelle de
revenus individuels
et quand vous pouvez le voir c'est
toujours très important si on combine le
bide de dire quoi par le temps bon à
part le cadre danemark allemagne avec un
faible un taux de pénalité et puis le
plus égalitaire de l'eau cellule en
termes de mobilité la générationnel en
termes d'une gare de ce clavier socio
professionnelle éducation et santé s'est
élevé donc là et on voit si on veut nous
avons été amis viré il rime pour l'est
pas donc c'est plus facile attendre hall
est simple ils ont par contre c'est
assez faible dans les eaux donc il ya un
plafond verront enfin les signaux l'afld
a lancé c'est un secteur
par contre si vous donnez tous les
autres pays il ya mélange des
qualifications et qu'il faut en gros 30
donc là il ya les pays nordiques j'ai la
belgique
non je préfére en vo que sur la france
en france dont j'avais comme ça a été
mon swing tout à l'heure le niveau des
inégalités de revenus et moyennes vous
faites un peu sous la moyenne c'est
français numéro ou formule être en super
de l'eau cellule il faut quand même dire
que ça augmente et le dernier deux ans
mais on sait pas où il se trouve dans un
groupe de pays avec l'allemagne
l'australie le canada
maintenant si on va si on se focalise
sensibilité d'une gamme est ce qu'il
était devenu
et bien en france et en allemagne c'est
un débit de ses plus faibles comparaison
à vancouver
comparant avec le canada par exemple
par contre si tu connais la profession
ou la santé
si c'est notre culture et pour la
mobilité des revenus individuels
vous vouliez différents émotion et son
plus fort ou plus faibles et vue
d'ensemble
il convient toujours je me focalise sur
l'éducation et je compare le prix en
terme de deux ans messieurs les diplômes
etc où vous dites moi j'aimerais bien
avoir un ensemble et là je trouve par
exemple que nation comme l'australie
sont plus élevés qu'ailleurs par contre
c'est pas le cas si on regarde les gains
des activités gervinho avant dernier y
apprend ainsi son cinquième point que
j'aimerais mon souhait c'est surtout
qu'on va la vie on se rend compte que je
publie différents sujets de notre vie
mais aussi sur la mobilité sociale il
égalité des chances
nous avons mis en avant ce qu'il ya deux
grandes interventions qu'il faut
toujours mais
prendre en compte le premier à gauche
dans ces deux dom élaborer les
politiques qui peuvent et sont propres à
assurer l'égalité des chances pour tous
les enfants
donc ici on trouve un peu cette idée est
d'aller vite et les choses d'une
opportunité si vous voulez on à long
terme
il ya tout et je vais aller dans les
détails mais tout un plan d'une panoplie
de mesures issues des expériences des
pays comme avant en passant par
l'éducation et scolaires les périodes
l'éducation équilibre entre vie
familiale et personnelle
ils voulaient soutirer les situations
une eau de patrimoine qui s'en rend
compte ici mais en même temps et surtout
dans une situation de crise comme il ya
100 ans aujourd'hui ils font prendre
il faut aussi considérer volonté des
politiques atténue les conséquences
nationales du son qui favorable ça va de
soi et qui sont non plus des politiques
de conviction qu'ils sont et c'est très
fort et concrétisation c'est sur le
maché travail équivalent bien sûr aussi
à prendre en compte
témoigne je finis avec un petit focus
sur la france parmi ces deux grands axes
qui solde les éléments qui sont le plus
prometteur pour réduire les inégalités
promouvoir les mobiles et montpellier
france ou à identifier trois ans le
premier et étant de réduire les écarts
scolaire entre les enfants issus de
milieux socio-économiques différents
signes très souvent honte car bien que
la foncière de pilot c'est lui qui est
qui investit le plus en fait on est dans
le pré scolaire et dont les scolaires
on se rend compte avec elie assists et
on part qui même renforce des égards si
vous prenez par exemple la liste grise a
intérêt sinon numérique etc
la france se trouve combat mille autres
indicateurs en plus au dessus de la
moyenne mais si vous refaites un
différence entre lycéens et des
étudiants issus de familles favorisées
et d'y favoriser les cas est très grand
je ne les lis fortis a pour les enfants
issus de familles défavorisées sont au
top comme le japon ou la corée etc
tandis que les scores pisa des enfants
et ceux de new fabris est donc fort
hills et joue le toit dans la ville avec
le portugal donc qui vaut qu'on plus
grand qu'ailleurs
et je rajoute cet égard c'est ca comme
dit non ce qu'on pense souligné
deschamps c'est ma semaine mois contre l
exclusion et votre collègue de l'insee a
démontré que ces écarts se sont fait
peur au monde ils ont raconté il y a dix
quinze ans un contrat commencé pisa
c'était un peu pareil allemagne entre
tour d'allemagne un petit peu lisse et
maintenant nous savons bien que le film
conte en français
un lieu le chômage de longue durée parce
que et ça ça fait référence à la
mobilité entre générations mais plutôt
les chocs défavorables cas en france ya
plus de chômage au boulot ils ont plus
d'impact donc l'avion tout un éventail
de politiques qui sont partis les gens
en place mais qu'il faut voir améliorer
la façon de le céder en france et c'est
un exemple pour les autres pays
mais pour l'instant et ça couvre pas
suffisamment des travailleurs a exposé
qualification et finalement finalement
sen t bien démontré qu il faut
s'entraîner aux unités territoriales qui
sont plus grande france que dans
d'autres pays d'europe
je dirais presque faciale parce que
c'est en allant ici dit rien montré on
en a l'eau à l'intérieur des régions et
départements il ya bien sûr cette
question à la désintégration des masses
et à lyon qu'il y avait des disparités
énormes et ça en fait des appels à une
n1 q2 d'épisodes des avantages pour la
mobilité pour l'éducation l'éducation
préscolaire la longue voie de formation
à l'emploi mais aussi l'accès aux
services services un son et services
éducation services transports donc
cesser les trois ans qu'on a opposé pour
procéder à la france tant que j'y pense
une question sur un poste que vous avez
dit sur la carte que vous avez présenté
sur les inégalités on va dire en
fonction des régions
donc il ya quelques régions qui sont en
bleu foncé jeu passion pour elle à la
remettre peut-être quelques régions qui
sont qui sont en bleu foncé donc où on
va dire le l'espoir de progression
sociale je sais pas comment il faut le
qualifier est meilleur que dans d'autres
pourtant dans ces régions je parle de la
mienne en fait partir le la nouvelle
aquitaine donc je connais bien il ya de
fortes inégalités territoriales entre
eux il ya des zones extrêmement rurales
et des zones urbaines quand on vit à
bordeaux
en clair c'est complètement différent de
quand on vit dans à l'aise de mon
département entre le laisse des landes
et du lot-et-garonne
pourtant là toute la carte et bleu foncé
voilà c'est à dire que est ce qu'il ya
des 10es ce que ça veut dire que les
disparités sont prégnantes entre régions
ouest dans dans les régions en intra
elles n'ont pas été analysées alors
c'est vrai que la région aquitaine est
encore plus saillant nouvelle aquitaine
c'est un peu hétérogène
c'est peut-être un géré par un contre
exemple mais en tout cas c'est vrai
qu'on a des disparités
pas forcément
à la faveur de bordeaux enfin c'est à
dire que bordeaux s'en sort finalement
moins bien que le reste des territoires
paradoxalement y ait encore une fois on
compare des gens qui ont des origines
sociales modestes dans tous ces
territoires
on se concentre sur les les familles
populaires de bordeaux si vous comparez
sur cette carte il faut comparer
bordeaux à je sais pas le département
des landes ou au département de pyrénées
atlantiques
en fait vous comparez des familles
populaires de bordeaux avec des familles
populaires des landes
déjà c voilà c'est un exercice de pensée
qui n'est pas forcément très élevé mais
voilà on a essayé de neutraliser l'effet
de l'origine sociale donc ce n'est pas
bordeaux versus les landes ce que
bordeaux évidemment il ya plein de
classe moyenne ya aussi beaucoup de
cadres donc comparer bordeaux et les
landes
évidemment bordeaux en termes de destin
s'en sortirait mieux mais ça serait un
effet juste de l'origine sociale des
bordelais qui est plus favorable
sociologiquement que ceux des landes est
donc là vraiment on est sûr sur une
origine données et sur la question de la
ruralité
je n'ai pas dit mais les départements ne
donne pas moins de perspectives aux
individus qui grandissent dans notre
étude en tout cas mais c'est parce que
il ya un taux d'émigration qui est plus
important dans ces territoires là c'est
à dire que pour réussir quand on vient
d'un territoire rural ça ne se fera pas
forcément sur le territoire mais ça
appliquera donc derrière cette carte il
faut pas penser que les gens de la
creuse sont restés dans la creuse
peut-être que les gens de la creuse s'en
sortent bien ou mal ou peut-être je vais
prendre un autre exemple dans le
limousin
parce que ils ont profité d'une mobilité
vers une autre ville vers un autre
département
et donc voilà il ya d'autres dossiers
c'est la deuxième question que j'allais
poser parce que je ne voyais pas la
différence entre le fait d'évoluer dans
une vivre dans une zone rurale à très
rural et le fait de vivre dans une zone
urbaine et donc est ce que ça veut dire
tout simplement que pour
accédez à de meilleures conditions de
vie et il faut bouger il faut être
mobile physiquement spatialement alors
je te réponds d'une autre manière c'est
à dire que les les territoires les plus
ruraux les plus reculés compense un
développement économique plus faible par
le fait de donner d un niveau d
éducation correcte vous voire supérieurs
à la moyenne aux enfants qui grandissent
leur permettant à un parcours de
mobilité leur permettant d'avoir un
revenu plus important en tout cas ils
vont compenser un certain nombre de
régions d'ailleurs qui sont détaillées
dans la note
de mémoire il y avait il ya vait franche
comté il y avait
la région du limousin aussi qui sont
caractériels qui font qu'ils donnent
plus de perspectives que leur niveau de
développement économique aurait laissé
penser c'est à dire que justement par
plus d'éducation parfois par plus de
mobilité
j'arrive à compenser un développement
économique plus faible mais alors vous
allez me dire je ne saurais que répondre
que
évidemment on ne permet pas aux gens de
rester c'est sur le territoire est salée
donc là on est on est dans une
perspective individuelle c'est à dire
que on regarde vraiment l'égalité des
chances entre individus mais évidemment
on n'a pas de perspective sur les
territoires on ne dit pas dans quelle
mesure ces mouvements de mobilité
géographique vont après impact et le
développement du territoire
très bien allez-y vous avez des
questions
oui bonsoir merci beaucoup pour tout ces
présentations elles sont toutes très
intéressantes et puis je dirais cette
danse comme information je suis très
contente monsieur le président que vous
puissiez nous laisser l'accès à ces
documents qu'on aura besoin je pense de
relire à plusieurs reprises pour
véritablement se les approprier moi j'ai
voilà avant avant la réunion etc
j'ai été lire un certain nombre de
documents certain nombre d'informations
peut céder ou de l' ocde on voit un
moment donné que en france il semblerait
qu'il faille plus de six générations à
une personne du bas de la distribution
des revenus pour rejoindre la moyenne ce
qui est quand même quelque chose d'assez
révélateur et qui apparaît comme l'un
des plus mauvais scores au niveau de
cette zone ocde
c'est la raison d'ailleurs pour laquelle
souvent on dit l'ascenseur social en
france est en panne on voit aussi qu'un
certain non vous l'avez évoqué tous à
différents niveaux en fait de
différentes façons que effectivement le
le le déterminisme social n'est pas le
seul facteur et c'est quelque chose qui
est effectivement intéressant de
rappeler à un moment donné toutefois
aussi on voit dans d'autres lectures
dans d'autres documents y compris dans
vos propres instances
malgré tout le déterminisme revient et
puis on voit que le capital humain est
quand même pointé comme un facteur
important dans cette danse est
reproduction des inégalités
alors moi j'avais une question pour vous
3 si je puis dire enfin vous 4 qu'est ce
qui pénalise le plus la france sur ce
terrain là parce qu'en réalité l'arrêt
l'objectif que nous portons ici c'est de
pouvoir peut-être faire des propositions
du moins c'est le sens de cette mission
c'est de pouvoir trouver identifier les
problèmes pour pouvoir à un moment donné
faire des propositions ce que madame la
rapporteure fera vraisemblablement à
l'issue de tous ces échanges de toutes
ces auditions et une autre question que
j'aurais souhaité vous poser c'est les
des réformes menées à l'étranger audel
permis de traiter ces différents enjeux
parce que on a bien vu à travers les
différents éléments que vous avez
communiqué avec nous et les graves que
bon la france selon les différents
critères se situe différemment mais
malgré tout ce problème n'est pas
franco-français 1 le problème des
inégalités c'est quelque chose qui
interroge d'autres pays donc est-ce que
ailleurs il y aurait des exemples que
vous partageriez je dirais de manière un
petit peu avec une certaine acuité avec
nous aujourd'hui
voilà monsieur le président je vous
remercie qui répond qui s'y colle
étonnamment quelques pistes etc
c'est aux familles à il ya un an sur
huit rentiers de ses actionnaires à ses
mollets qui est qui décrit des
initiatives entreprises l'andante a
envie de nos cellules et donc mais il
faut toujours savoir de quoi peut-on
apprendre parce qu'il aurait si on fait
ça c'est exactement pour info un endroit
magnifique science et les autres et
politique implique min et qui n'est pas
convaincant
certains politiques n'ont par exemple
dans le même qui vit non centralisée
comme le mien et l'autriche
je n'oublie en france d'outre-mer contre
ce domaine donc très heureux juste mun
exemple mamiya cinquantaine si les
écoles qui il en est et l'horizon et
indemniser constitionnel des prix 10 15
20 ans par contre si on regarde s'il
semble
d'un côté la finlande ça ils le font
aussi
mais c'est qu'il faut en plus ces
données le mans courageusement aux profs
c'est plus qu'un encouragement par ils
sont enfin là les gens l'aient dans le
hall du pays dans le nord et en corée
dans la dénégation qui ayant eu de
problèmes le chômage c'est bien c'est
nous gagner une fois plus à séoul au toc
ou dans un avion des gens plus favorisés
il s'appelle parce qu'elle est aussi son
ami c'était sociale bon ça c'est
l'éducation mais on a pris plusieurs
champs d'action donc l'éducation mais
aussi les politiques de logement un
exemple c'est l'autre c'est un peut
s'interroger on peut comparer quelques
points qui le joue un peu mieux être
lotis pour permettre à plus d'égalité
s'il voulait par exemple peut-être c'est
un bonne idée de ne pas trop focaliser
j'ai créé des zones mais mixer les
socios qui va exemple à viège a consisté
en persan de tout le logement et où vous
avez une sorte
j'ai un regret complicité des locataires
pas seulement défavorisés il savait dire
que de mélanger
mais cet exemple je ferai en parler
longtemps mais je pense ça se vaut la
peine de regarder ailleurs les tout
temps et ce en toute conscience ainsi
intéressant qui peut être suivie
d'autres arts et violent les asini par
ne le peuvent pas
alors je vais essayer de répondre mais
bien sûr le problème est très complexe
très multifactorielle et affront
stratégie on n'a pas formuler de
recommandations précises de politiques
publiques que ce soit sur l'éducation ou
d'autres d'autres secteurs mais en tout
cas on discute plusieurs pistes dans
lequel les politiques publiques
devraient investir plus donc si on
reprend l'analyse territoriales ce que
ça donne quand même beaucoup d'idées de
dire que voilà il ya certaines régions
qui s'en sortent moins bien et certains
quartiers
en termes de perspectives pour les
individus la caractéristique de la
france est quand même qu'on a ces deux
zones au nord et au sud
et ça rejoint ce que disait michael
foster tout à l'heure on a une égalité
territoriale importante avec deux
régions qui cumulent des difficultés
donc languedoc-roussillon par l'ancienne
région du languedoc-roussillon et puis
nord pas de calais un peu plus voilà la
somme l'aisne et est en fait c'est une
région qui depuis 40 ans cumule toujours
les mêmes problèmes avec des taux de
chômage important un revenu plus faible
assez peu de convergence vers les autres
territoires c'est à dire qu' il ya des
territoires qui étaient pauvres qui
convergent manifestement en france c'est
le cas de la corse et cadets d'hommes et
qui partent d'un niveau développement
plus faible mais qui on note une
certaine convergence économique sur le
nord et le sud de la france
métropolitaine on constate pas ça et
donc ça veut dire que on a après des
dynamiques qui se mettre en oeuvre sur
sur le long terme qui vont être
défavorable des individus donc on
insiste vraiment sur le fait qu' il faut
avoir une politique qui vit ces deux
grosses régions c'est ensemble de
territoires défavorisés
que ce soit par des politiques
incitatives pour inciter les entreprises
à localiser des emplois de qualité ou à
réorganiser leurs
leur force de travail pour mettre des
emplois dans ces territoires là sur
l'emploi public aussi peut-être qu'une
en tout cas à court terme y aurait un
intérêt pour l'état à localiser un
certain nombre d'emplois dans ces
territoires là d'autant que dans un truc
à ces territoires sont peu dotées en
emplois publics par habitant et puis et
puis ensuite voilà que dire de plus que
2 d'inciter encore et toujours sur le
poids de l'éducation est évidemment là
c'est un champ de recherche
tellement vaste je ne vais pas de
recommandations aux politiques publiques
particulière mais il faut voir si on
veut améliorer l'égalité des chances ça
passera forcément par l'éducation donc
les politiques de michael foster parler
de mixité sociale de ciblage voilà mais
on n'a pas de formulation plus plus
précises là dessus par contre je voulais
quand même et je le fais à chaque fois
j'ai encore le faire aujourd'hui revenir
sur ce chiffre des six générations qu'il
faut un ménage modeste pour enfin à une
famille modeste pour revenir à la
moyenne qui est un chiffre qui a eu
beaucoup de succès qui est tiré de dieu
rapport de l' ocde en fin de
l'introduction du rapport de l' ocde qui
était énormément repris et c'est très
bien parce que ça ça a favorisé le débat
sur ces questions là le secours
populaire a fait aussi une affiche qui
est dans le métro qu'on voit partout
oui je voulais quand même rappeler les
précautions à avoir avec ce chiffre là
notamment sur les données j'en ai déjà
parlé mais aussi même sur
l'interprétation du résultat c'est un
calcul qui qui est théorique qui qui est
vise à prendre le coefficient d'inertie
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure des
40% est elle appliquée de manière
successive sur général sur six
générations de voir qu'est-ce que ça
produit comme comme trajectoire sur les
revenus et donc le problème c'est que
on a ce chiffre de 40% aujourd'hui en
france on a absolument aucune donnée sur
le long terme sur la trajectoire des
individus sur aussi génération aucun
pays qui a des données aussi précises
donc voilà c'est un calcul vraiment
théorique et d'autre part sur les six
générations qu'il faut pour revenir à la
moyenne en fait au bout de trois
générations
si on reprend la méthodologie au bout de
trois générations on a déjà on a déjà
arrivé à 85 % de l'écart donc on a déjà
on est déjà revenu il reste plus que 15
% à parcourir
d'accord c'est un peu compliqué c'est
lié au fait qu'on on a quelque chose qui
n'est pas linéaire enfin je vous pouvez
vous expliquer peut-être si j'avais plus
de temps mais mais en gros voilà au au
bout de six générations on est revenu à
la moyenne mais au bout de trois
générations ont été déjà pratiquement
arrivé à la moyenne et il faut encore
trois générations 6 supplémentaires pour
combler ce petit écart voilà juste pour
pour inciter à la prudence sur ce
chiffre
nous avons notre collègue taillé et poli
yankee et en visioconférence qui aurait
une une question et qui sera si vous
êtes d'accord la dernière puisque nous
avons déjà dépassé le temps imparti et
nous sommes dans le temps additionnel on
vous entend en tentant parfaitement très
bien merci infiniment merci novateur et
sur sur cette question des inégalités
est ce que ça dit monsieur de francs
stratégie en fait me permets de poser
cette question de manière plus affinée
parce qu'en réalité la question que je
me posais c'est monsieur parler beaucoup
en terme de moyenne est notamment évoqué
le fait que les inégalités en moyenne en
france ne connaissait pas de
d'approfondissement mais qu'en est il
des écarts à la moyenne parce que
effectivement on a connu notamment
cc c'est en mesurant quelques dizaines
d'années les écarts de salaires
notamment l'intérieur des entreprises
qui se sent énormément accrue
donc on parle de moyenne certes mais là
on parle justement de franchissement de
génération mais c'est il s'agit donc de
franchir les quarts entre n'avons pas et
la moyenne et 6 5 eca s'agrandit même si
ça concerne moins de population
c'est d'autant plus difficile de vaincre
la propreté et la relégation sociale que
cela implique donc c'était ma question
c'est là l'évolution des écarts à la
moyenne et puis deuxièmement je vais
appuyer en tout cas donc rapporteur
spécial sur la mission travaille donc
des politiques publiques de retour à
l'emploi par rapport à ce que disait
monsieur forster sur la question du
chômage de longue durée je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas les moyens qui
sont vraiment mis notamment en termes de
dette accompagnement pour les chômeurs
de longue durée et qui serait important
je pense pour réduire les inégalités
dans le pays de te mettre vraiment
l'accent sur là-dessus parce que
finalement on a des politiques de
l'emploi qui qui aide à maintenir un
stock pendant les mois les mots j'aime
le jeu mais je ne valide pas
personnellement mais malheureusement
c'est un peu comme ça parfois qu'on peut
analyser les politiques d'emploi
on cherche à faire tourner les
populations qui sont vite vite vite se
retrouver un emploi les populations qui
sont assez facilement entre l'inné
employables est par contre on délaisse
les chômeurs de longue durée qui veut je
dirais s'enlise dans les difficultés la
pauvreté et donc évidemment favorise
qu'à passer à basse je sais pas si le
terme d'inr sylla correspond avec avec
les uns des termes qui a été employé les
mots statistiques mais voilà en tout cas
en lisent les personnes dans ces
situations là et je crois qu'en termes
politiques publiques on aurait fort à
faire en plus évidemment des questions
de d'éducation pour aider à la réduction
des inégalités de génération en
génération
voilà mes remarques et questions merci
monsieur le président
je précise et mon propos sur le
graphique que j'ai présentée tout à
l'heure il s'agissait des distributions
de salaires donc sur le marché du
travail s'était les salaires des hommes
puisque la littérature est très
focalisée sur les liens entre les
positions des pères et des fils j'avais
préféré publier ces données là donc
c'est un graphique qui présente le
rapport entre le des neuf et le deun
donc ça veut dire le seuil des 10% les
plus les mieux payés rapporté au seuil
des 10% les moins bien payés et donc là
on a une baisse au cours du temps
c'est vrai que dans le débat public on a
tendance à penser que de toutes les
inégalités augmentent si on a un joli
travail c'est pas si flagrant que ça
parce qu'en fait dans les années 90 vous
aviez quand même un certain nombre de
secteurs qui est qu'ils avaient un poids
important où il y avait des inégalités
importantes et le poids de ces secteurs
là a plutôt baissé au cours du temps par
contre évidemment si on regarde d'autres
aspects donc là c'est un rapport des
neuf sur des airs donc on regarde pas ce
qui se passe tout en haut de l'échelle
des salaires
si vous regardez les très très hauts
salaires là en effet depuis une
quinzaine d'années on augmente on
observe que ces très hauts salaires ils
augmentent +1 porte de façon plus
importante que les autres mais mais
d'une part ça ne joue pas beaucoup sur
le niveau de mobilité sociale de
l'ensemble de la population on est
vraiment sur une partie très très
restreinte du marché du travail et
d'autre part pour comme je disais pour
le pour le reste de la population on a
plutôt une réduction des inégalités
donc là je parle des revenus des
salaires si on est sur les patrimoines
on aurait encore d'autres diagnostics là
il faudrait regarder plus en détail les
données de de thomas piketty notamment
et de ses co auteurs qui regarde
l'évolution du patrimoine et notamment
encore une fois des très gros
patrimoines au cours du temps et encore
une fois la france sert qu'à une
augmentation mais ce n'est pas une
augmentation qui a aussi importante que
dans certains autres pays comme les
etats-unis donc donc j'insisterai
vraiment sur le fait que de manière
contre intuitive
la france est plutôt le pays qui a le
plus contenue les inégalités de
patrimoine et réduit les inégalités de
revenus même si elle reste à un niveau
important et est encore une fois
attention de ne pas tout vendre de ne
pas mélanger patrimoine est revenu et
d'essayer d'avoir un débat documenté sur
ces questions là ça me paraît vraiment
essentiel nous avons notre collègue
laurent saumon qui est une question
siffler oui merci je encore que le cadre
légal retenu la profession donc ça c'est
le côté plutôt d'origine sociale et
l'autre l'éducation et la santé qui plus
d'origine j'allais dire d'autres
domaines des politiques publiques
justement là que vous avez un métier
dont je m'interrogeais de savoir si en
france vous avez dit également dans la
première présentation que les moyens qu
ennemi par exemple sur l'éducation
étaient parmi les plus élevés au niveau
européen malgré des résultats qui ne
sont pas satisfaisants et aussi de lait
de l'analyse territoriale sénateurs dans
les hauts de france et donc
effectivement on a ce souci de cumuler
un certain nombre de données difficiles
est ce que ça voudrait dire in fine et
que à la fois gérer un certain nombre de
politiques nationales publiques tels
l'aménagement du territoire qui a été
abandonnée convergence économique pour
voir une amélioration de la situation
dans les territoires
je pense en particulier à la bretagne
par exemple là qu'il a réussi et la
politique de la ville est ce que ça a
été mesurée pour savoir si c'est
politique de la ville qui touche un peu
plus l'eau mais à l'éducation à la santé
au logement
est ce que dans les analyses que vous
avez pu faire vous avez plus analysé des
améliorations suite à ces mesures le
public qui ont été prises elles n' y
aura une très importante il ya en france
où est ce que finalement on pourrait
constater que c'est un échec
une question que je ne peux pas répondre
disons trois quarts du rapport et
analytiques sont cons pierrick contal
les indicateurs et on fait les
indications fausses et pas pire
ensuite nous avons regardé des exemples
par pays
par contre par exemple de l'appétit de
ville il n'y a pas un avantage de les
comparer entre pays et nous avons passé
à à part en fait on a fait deux pays de
rugby + a approfondi où nous avons parlé
avec les acteurs géopolitiques et c'est
pour promouvoir un rapport de 560 pages
sur ce c'était surtout bispécifiques où
on a traité exactement ces questions
mais je vais proposer à nos comités
internes aux cellules ce genre dévolu il
ne l'est pas je suis pour l'instant pour
la france en salle
ça démontre vraiment aimé ne jamais me
semblent plus profondes dit pour
vraiment pouvoir aussi suivre dans le
temps mais possible succès ou pas
d'appeler sa politique notamment à petit
quevilly
j'aurais voulu qu'on veut aussi redonner
un commentaire d'intervention tout à
l'heure sur le briton ploie et de faste
chômage de longue durée etc y en a je
lui avant tient mais c'est nous mais
toujours n'avance l'importance des
politiques la fiche de match et aurait
enfin ça appelle à des politiques
préventif et dans une sombre j'ai eu
avant-hier que c'est qui pour les
politiques
c'est mon attirer le touriste italien il
n'ya rien aucun électorale qui va dire
vous avez
ici à revenir on n'a pas beaucoup de
chômage de longue durée etc
donc c'est beaucoup plus difficile à
promouvoir d'avoir du succès dans ses
politiques préventif qui sont par
exemple très actives
il ya dans le rapport en folie très
simple graphique où on montre l'effort
qui est fait en politique préventive
pour les marchés travail et le risque à
des travailleurs les glaçons dans la
classe moyenne de glisser vers le bas
pour ces spécialistes mobilité négatif
et s'il ya très très clair mais bien sûr
et c'est pas un graphique chez nous où
vous allez trouver françois roux en même
temps dans le monde parce que c'est ça
ça rappelle le succès de politique on
and on en sait voler c'est beaucoup plus
facile en prime avant tout politique qui
passe après ça vient ya crise
en fait au match et les prestations mais
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont là les
prestations évidemment c'est qu'on
constate que les images ils n'ont pas
augmenté autant par exemple en france
l'année dernière qu' on aurait pu le
craindre parce que les prestations ont
joué un rôle mais ça et c'est très
facile à démontrer on peut faire si vous
voulez tout le discours là c'est sûr le
succès pour le volet dit préventif
c'est beaucoup plus difficile mais je
reviens il ya bien sûr une question sur
la santé si j'ai bien compris parce que
c'est moi je tenais beaucoup qu'avant
mais aussi un peu mon et il faut qu'elle
entend dans ce rapport et là encore il
ya un autre principe hyper simple
qui montre le pays qui donne plus
d'efforts mais mon alter tout simplement
car le personnel au pot en santé se
retrouvent tout au long de l'essai de
positif de mobilité dans la santé donc
les politiques et en maintenant votre
question précise
ccn deuxième étape samedi matin puis il
faut passer de 2 comme on irait chaque
système politique à des mesures et là il
faut vraiment une piste que j'aimerais
bien sûr comme un tube à monique merci
monsieur le président de rallonger bref
c'est un petit peu un petit peu juste
pour mesdames de de l'insee est-ce que
je résume bien est-ce que j'ai bien
compris
si je dis que la mobilité sociale
récollets que les choses ont progressé
ou plutôt progressé depuis je peux à
partir de quand vous faites partir votre
analyse 64 c'est ça 60 mais qu' elle
stagne par contre 2 c'est ça est ce que
vous diriez donc la situation d'une
génération par rapport à une autre s'est
considérablement améliorée jusqu'aux
années 80 90 et que depuis la
progression s'est n'ont pas arrêté mais
ralenti est ce que c'est bien ça et pour
compléter la question de monique si je
puis me permettre
est-ce que
la croissance en france et c'est entre
guillemets on connais quand même des
vins difficiles depuis les années 90
2000 est ce que ces lits aussi et la
mobilité sociale était lié directement à
la croissance économique
comme vous avez dit tout à l'heure que
c'était stagnant depuis quéven un palier
dans les années 90 et que ça va partir
des années 90 2000 koala plus forcément
de croissance dans ce pays parce que
c'est lié cela ça c'est pas quelque
chose que l'étude fait relier la
croissance est là la mode le taux de
mobilité sociale une des
une des raisons aussi de la stagnation
du taux de mobilité sociale ou de là
conduire de la par exemple pour les uns
de la réduction de la prédominance des
mouvements ascendants sur le mouvement
ascendant
elle est aussi lié au fait que là il ya
eu un essor une qualification des
emplois qui a beaucoup progressé
justement jusqu'au milieu des années 90
et ensuite cette manière cette
croissance de la qualification des
emplois c'est s'est ralentie et ça
c'était une des explications avancées au
fait qu' on
mouzon resté un peu sur des chiffres
assez assez stable et la dernière
question je fais été posée vous avez
souligné monsieur l'importance de
l'éducation
on sent effectivement c'est quelque
chose que nous relevons régulièrement
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il y a des
disparités importantes sur le territoire
normalement l'éducation si je prends le
vocable éducation nationale l'éducation
qui est dispensée à tous les enfants est
la même dans le pays or ça ne ça ne se
remarque pas quand on regarde les
différents graphiques que vous nous avez
montré
donc est ce que ça veut dire qu' il
faudrait arriver peut-être à des
politiques différenciées en fonction des
territoires ont garé dans une base
commune
mais en faisant des efforts
supplémentaires dans certaines parties
du territoire
et qu'est ce que vous pensez aussi de
tout ce qui n'est pas délivré par
l'école c'est-à-dire qui concourent à
l'éducation des enfants
mais en dehors de l'école nous avons
aujourd'hui des familles qui peuvent
être déficiente et pas forcément dans
que dans les milieux sociaux extrêmement
défavorisés
nous avons me semble-t-il des mouvements
je l'avais dit en introduction avec jean
alors qu'il s'agisse je parle de je veux
choquer personne mais c'étaient des
mouvements populaires il y avait aussi
des mouvements religieux
je parle pas mouvement religieux au sens
où on l'entend aujourd'hui mais je me
souviens quand j'étais en forme pour
être clair en zone rurale il y avait ce
qu'on appelait la ji ou c fin des
organismes comme ça qu'ils qui
structurait qui proposait des activités
aux enfants qui qui permettait de rester
dans certains cadres tout ça aujourd'hui
complètement éclatée et je pense
d'ailleurs qu'au contraire on peut voir
l'émergence de certains mouvements
religieux mais qui
mais qui n'ont pas tout à fait même
vocation donc je ferai attention à ce
que je dirais sur ce sujet là n'est ce
pas mais enfin aujourd'hui tout un tas
de mouvements ont disparu les mouvements
d'éducation populaire souffre et
pourtant je suis convaincu qu'ils ont
une importance capitale pour aider à
réduire les inégalités
est-ce que ce que vous avez déjà un
petit peu travaillé enfin j'imagine
là-dessus ce que vous avez des choses
c'est très vaste excusez moi en fin de
réunion mais vous parlez d effet de
contexte en fait fin
dans les différences territoriales on
sait que le contexte historique social
du territoire va jouer c'est comme ça il
ya des territoires
je sais pas on peut citer l'aveyron par
exemple il ya une spécificité de
l'aveyron les les structures sociales ne
sont pas les mêmes en aveyron que en
lozère et il ya eu beaucoup plus de
mobilité géographique en provenance de
l'aveyron historiquement depuis 200 ans
c'est comme ça il ya un contexte et en
fait on peut dire ça pour beaucoup de
territoires c'est à dire que finalement
les politiques publiques sont assez peu
attentive au contexte on a des
politiques qui appliquent des politiques
qui sont parmi les politiques qui
appliquent des objectifs qui sont
déterminés à un niveau national et
finalement les effets de contexte ont
assez peu pris en compte
ensuite c'est très difficile de prendre
en compte ces effet de contexte
c'est facile de dire qu'il est qu'ils
existent et qu'ils jouent sur les
destins mais faire que les politiques
éducatives arrive à compenser ces effets
de contexte les prendre en compte c'est
c'est quelque chose de très très
compliqué en tout cas on n'a jamais
réussi à progresser sur cette question
notamment font stratégie mais ailleurs
il n'y a pas vraiment de boîte à outils
très simples sur ces questions là et
puis en plus comme je disais il ya le
territoriales mais il ya aussi l'origine
sociale qui est très hétérogène sur sur
un territoire c'est à dire que sur une
agglomération sur une commune de toute
façon il ya des personnes d'origines
sociales différentes qui vont se
retrouver dans des dans des
établissements scolaires et on n'est pas
capable de cibler les différents
individus au sein d'un établissement fin
ça on fait ça très très difficilement et
donc à l'échelle d'un territoire ta joue
sajou aussi comment est ce qu'on fait ce
qu'il faut stimuler un territoire est ce
qu'il faut cibler certains des individus
sur certains territoires
ça pose des questions très compliquées
et je voulais parler aussi de quelque
chose que j'aurais dû dire dès le départ
de ma présentation c'est que j'ai
beaucoup insisté sur les aspects
territoriaux de l'inégalité des chances
mais le facteur territoriale joue quand
même moins que l'origine sociale donc
je parlais d'un écart de 1000 euros
entre un enfant de cas d'un enfant
d'ouvrier à l'âge adulte au niveau
territorial surtout un écart de 300
euros enfin voila c'est pour donner des
chiffres pour situer les ordres de
grandeur et donc du coup si on veut
favoriser l'égalité des chances c'est la
question territoriale va être importante
mais la question sociale l'est tout
autant
et donc ça pose les mêmes problèmes de
ciblage au sein des établissements au
sein des territoires et et je n'ai pas
les éléments pour vous donner des idées
plus concrètes sur ces questions là en
tout cas questions courtes réponses
courtes
merci beaucoup monsieur le président je
me rends compte que j'abuse peut sans
doute du temps mais c'est passionnant
moi j'avais juste une dernière question
très courte sur le genre en fait
mesdames vous avez évoqué des études où
on voyait la comparaison mère fille père
fils est en fait vous avez évoqué à la
marche que parfois on faisait fi perd en
revanche qu'est ce que ça donne en
résultat si on devait faire une tout
simplement une comparaison est ce que
cela a été fait enfants parents c'est à
dire que au delà du genre pourquoi ce je
dirais ce comparatif genre et je ne suis
pas à vous voyez je n'ai pas vos
compétences vos expertises ma question
vous paraît peut-être anachronique mais
j'aimerais comprendre merci beaucoup
alors traditionnellement l'analyse de la
mobilité sociale se fait il fait en
comparant des enfants de même genre dont
conflit nanami souvent c'est la peinture
fils l'étude
tout à fait on trouve généralement dans
la littérature des éléments qui compare
les fils au père donc là pour nous la
nouveauté ça a était d'introduire la
mobilité sociale des femmes puisque
c'est devenu un élément important à
prendre en compte dans l'avenir aussi de
la mobilité sociale
donc la question était de savoir comment
intégrer les femmes au centre cette
analyse donc la première idée a été de
comparer d'abord les filles alors merde
évidemment été on a été contraint
problème de chiens d' analyse puisque
plus on recule d'antan moi il y arrive
il y avait deux femmes qui travaillent
en activité donc il a été important de
compléter les premiers éléments finis
mer par une analyse complémentaire fille
père après des éléments sur la mobilité
sociale enfants parents ça n'a pas été
fait et en photos voyez enfin très
prosaïquement on prend la catégorie
socioprofessionnelle d'une personne il
faut la comparer à quelque chose de donc
si on dit les parents qu'est il faut
pouvoir définir une catégorie
socioprofessionnelle des parents donc
sacré nationaux ont choisi toujours une
personne pendant très très longtemps ça
toujours été le père parce que c'était
l'homme qui travaillait là aujourd'hui
depuis conseil national information
statistique a travaillé sur la question
il ya compte de travail donc il ya une
une proposition de pcs définies au
niveau du ménage donc effectivement qui
prend en compte le fait d'être en couple
et qui définit quelque chose au niveau
arabe au niveau des ménages ont soit au
niveau d'une personne si elle est seule
soit au niveau 6 au niveau du couple
après c'est une notion qu'on essayait
ces derniers temps de mobiliser pour
travailler un peu sur ces questions de
trajectoire mais qui n'est pas simple
non plus d'utiliser parce qu'elle mêle à
la fois des notions de catégorie socio
professionnelle individuelle et aussi de
sa trajectoire matrimoniale en fait ça
est très maniable conjugale équipe ce
qui pose aussi des problèmes de
comparaison parce que il faut
hiérarchiser
enfin on se met hiérarchiser aussi des
choses enfin des trajectoires conjugales
voilà donc c'est passé pas si aisé que
ça d'arriver à comparer enfin comparer
une personne personne non life a mal à
le faire comparer une personne fin voilà
définir le milieu social de manière
générale en quand on commence à regarder
le père la mère folle à les mettre
ensemble c'est pas si simple que ça en
fait points je voulais juste faire une
observation il faut penser aux familles
monoparentales qui sont de plus en plus
présente dans notre société
donc voilà je moi j'aimerais je
plaiderai pour que nos façons de faire
les statistiques évoluent aussi dans ce
sens là en fait qu'on en tienne compte
le plus on tient beaucoup compte 240 ha
dans les statistiques de l'insee vous
les retrouverez
dans tous nos chiffres enfin on
elles sont elles sont bien pris en
compte leur on sait que leur niveau de
vie sont moins bons leur taux de
pauvreté très fort enfin en servant une
catégorie comprend de façon assez
systématique en compte
[Musique]